the MCU has built its own continuity
over the last 11 years many of the
references in each of these films have
become about the movies themselves not
just the comic book source material but
there are still nuggets tucked away in
the movies for the longtime comics fans
here are some of the Easter eggs in
Avengers endgame major spoilers for the
film are ahead of course at the end of
the 1991 story the Infinity Gauntlet
Thanos is sent off to an unnamed planet
for time out to think about what he's
done the Thanos of endgame meets a very
different end twice but we do find the
post nap Thanos who appears early on in
the movie similarly situated on a planet
without a name like the Thanos of
infinity gauntlet he's taken up a quiet
life of farming having placed his armor
on a steak as a scarecrow later the
Avengers built gauntlet of the movie
becomes almost a literal football with
different carriers running it down the
field toward ant-man's van in the comic
it also passes between numerous holders
including nebula who seizes it from
Thanos the two movie nebulas play both
sides of the conflict over the gauntlet
another Infinity Gauntlet nod comes when
Captain America prepares to march up to
Thanos alone to face him one-on-one
until the revived heroes arrive it's
reminiscent of the comics moment where
Captain America stares down Thanos fully
aware he's walking into certain death
one of the biggest applause moments in
the movie comes when Captain America
reaches out his hand and summons the
Mjolnir Thor retrieved from Asgard not
only has cap wielded Thor's hammer in
the comics before it's actually happened
multiple times it first goes down in
Thor number 390 from 1988 Thor gets
knocked to the ground by a particularly
nasty foe named grog the god crusher
dropping his hammer in the process Steve
Rogers in his identity as simply the
captain goes to retrieve it and not only
picks it up but takes out a bunch of
henchmen in the process in the 2011
event series fear itself upon Thor's
apparent death Steve Rogers lifts the
hammer once again to rally the Avengers
and probably the most controversial
instance the Hydra allegiant version of
Captain America raises the hammer and
2017 s secret Empire the moment is also
a callback to Avengers age of Ultron
where Steve tries to lift me ol near but
it doesn't quite pull it off
a lot of MCU superheroes have daughters
that appear in endgame and almost all of
them are direct or indirect versions of
characters from comics the most direct
comics connection is Cassie Lange who
appears in endgame as a teenager in the
comics she's a teenaged sighs changing
superhero who goes by the name of
stature and joins the Young Avengers
Scott even remarks to her in the movie
you're so big I ain't fair for breakfast
super cool in end games opening moments
we see clint barton training a young
girl who we find out is his daughter
lilah in archery a quick glimpse of that
scene in the trailer had some observers
thinking the girl might be Kate bishop
who also goes by hawkeye in the comics
it isn't but as sure not decayed occurs
when Clint calls Lila Hawkeye then
there's Morgan stark Tony's daughter who
loves him 3,000 in the comics however
Morgan Stark is a very different
character he's Tony's cousin and
believes Tony's dad stole all his ideas
from his father he teams up with
supervillain count nefaria to try to
kill Tony and later turns into a giant
living robot
he doesn't love Tony 3000 a lingering
question from Avengers infinity war was
whether any of the Asgardians who were
in the ship Thanos attacked survived to
resettle on earth as they plan to do at
the end of thor ragnarok buddhism
endgame lets us know that they did
building a small but thriving new Asgard
community headed up by Valkyrie in
Thor's absence though there's never been
a comics version of Asgard in the Nordic
region there have been a couple times
Asgard came to earth the version
actually called new Asgard is from a
story where an alternate future Thor has
become Lord of both earth and Asgard in
the year 2020 and Asgard has been
rebuilt over the remains of a devastated
New York City once all that got reversed
Thor eventually created a version of
Asgard on a giant landmass hovering
nearby the town of Broxton Oklahoma for
a while many of the hair and costume
choices and endgame either point to the
passage of time like black widows blonde
red to tone hair mix or dig into the
history of the MCU Captain America wears
almost every previous movie costume to
character looks are definite nods to
comic fans though the red and blue
ensemble Rocket wears is a version of
the red and blue out
rocket in the rest of the guardians of
the galaxy team war after the mid-2000s
annihilation event
there's also captain Marvel's new
haircut which rocket cracks a joke about
just after the five-year jump it's very
similar to the hairstyle Carol Danvers
currently sports in the comics and which
she's had since taking up the Captain
Marvel name in 2012 Gwyneth Paltrow's
Pepper Potts wears one of Tony's suits
in Iron Man 3 and later gets superpowers
by the end of the movie but she hadn't
had a flying armored suit all her own
until the final act of Avengers endgame
who's the hot mess now still debatable
though she isn't called by the name in
the movie this is undoubtedly the MCS
version of rescue the armored identity
comics pepper took up in 2009's
invincible Iron Man number 10 in that
story Tony goes underground having been
publicly shamed for a recent squirrel
invasion pepper is tasked with running
Stark Industries responsibly upon
unleashing her fury at Tony by throwing
a chair at the wall she opens up a
secret room with the rescue armor inside
and begins her super heroic career in
the movie Tony makes the armor for her
willingly no chair throwing required the
Hulk's absence and the trailers for
endgame was a very curious thing fans
who have seen the movie now know that it
was to hide a pretty big reveal five
years in the future Banner and the Hulk
have figured out a way to coexist as one
entity it's a very similar concept to
the version of the Hulk who had come to
be known as Professor Hulk who first
appeared in 1991's Incredible Hulk
number 377 the movie version is a little
more friendly and a little less openly
menacing than the comics version one
moment of sizeable Hulk's strength from
the movie is when he holds up rubble to
protect rocket and Rhodey from being
crushed under the debris of Avengers
headquarters that moment has got to be
an allusion to Secret Wars number 4 in
which the pre professor Hulk has to hold
up the weight of an entire mountain
range to save his friends instead of
popping straight back to the present
after returning the Infinity stones to
their rightful places the MCU Captain
America chooses to stay in the past to
finally have that dance with Peggy
Carter
you're gonna need a rain check on that
dance Jiri emerges as an old man having
lived a full life and presents his
shield to falcon to take up his legacy
in the comics Sam Wilson has also
sidelined his Falcon persona to be
Captain America starting in 2015 he
starred in his own Captain America
series for a while
Sam's stint with the shield also
coincided with Steve Rogers becoming an
old man two comics Steve's aging was the
result of a conflict with the villainous
iron nail who neutralized his Super
Soldier Serum will end games Stan Lee
cameo be the last one in the MCU if so
it's a fitting tribute to the brash and
undeniably charismatic figure he cut
Lee's appearance comes when Tony Stark
and Steve Rogers are forced to travel
back to 1970 for another chance at
recovering the tesseract the world of
1970 comes to life when we see Lee
looking much like he did in the 70s
driving a muscle car by a military base
shouting at one of the guards make love
not war the bumper sticker on his car
carries one of his many catchphrases
nuff said not much more we can add to
that true believers check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Avengers endgame are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]